hae-jin so why are you um always gonna
work out here lately look to shape
looking gay he does look in shape I'm
not getting his running shoes you don't
worry about a guy those running shoes
Jim yeah there are any shoes yeah
comfortable ones too
they look like they've been worked on
their little dirty it looked like
they've been on the road and I'll tell
you something else it's a man who takes
in who studies a male a male frame I
mean now is he
51 year old gay man take me as a video
at one year old game and a big old I'm
looking at his forearms they're looking
a little vascular and they'll tell you
something right now I wouldn't be
surprised at this mysterious son of a
[ __ ] who we know nothing about and I
mean nothing zero I wouldn't be
surprised if he's moonlighting in a
boxing gym getting ready to piece me up
and I and by the way he's got a wide
face I'm gonna have some trouble
connecting or you can't miss I can't
miss one of two things he might get that
hon energy and shrug it off true and
then I'm gonna have to then I'm gonna
have to really pepper I'm on a new
trainer right now I mean I'm getting
some exercise in I knew it what top five
now can I can I get my dana white
promotion on and do do this in july july
is dry enough time we can do it right
away july i don't want to give him two
lies a lot of time actually I figured
summer the summer bod do you want to
what you want to do it before actually
you know what I think it probably it's
probably better in July because I turned
41 by the time it's July then I'll be
exactly 10 years that's good idea
younger than Brian and I don't care
about that it sounds what mine years
what about what let's see you Lucy
whatever in March so March April May say
June first week of June do we have an
agreement
I think first week of June yeah first
week of June it's gonna be really hot
that time shinra's count is on thank you
for their gentlemen shirts contracts to
come all right I'm excited I'm excited
too gonna start training gins been
training haha keep your head moving
bright Chin's been trained well she's
been trained in that yesterday I tried
to tell me as you get in
with the guys a really good amateur I
had some pro fights what you'll do I
don't know why you do they're moving
around then what I'll do is I'll catch
him cuz they're smaller and light you
catch if they're high level right so
I'll hit him with a jab and then maybe
I'll a hook and and then I'm like dude I
did well today by the way I didn't
really get hit I was good I kept my disc
and then what happens is a couple weeks
later we spar again and I'm I'm jumping
around a little cocky and then they let
you know without really even hurting you
they just let you know this this
gentleman who's from Mexico [ __ ] so
much smaller than me and just doesn't
get tired beat me up Vanilla's too long
to think you can beat these guys and I
fell to the ground no but I got so tired
up and you're supposed to move other way
I was too tired to move on I just
grabbed him and hung on him just hung on
them and then I after two rounds I fell
to the ground I was like fatigued as the
Vince Lombardi makes a coward of us all
yeah it does you know what dude keep it
up man if I really apply myself by the
time I'm 55 all [ __ ] aside
you could beat up your I'm stepping in
saving everybody Mickey Rourke
you want me to promote you verse Mickey
Rourke be I'll beat him we'll call it
wrinkles I like Mickey I don't know you
seen the hell that man trains you're
seeing with the double end bag I don't
care any he had some pro boxing
experience sure but yeah I love he's
also a crazy I love him as an actor do
me a favor we've done this before
think we've seen it all let's move right
how about the anyways how would the
picture I'd say yesterday with the with
the face mascot hello that's my job my
job get it first of all you ready yeah
Sol Sol Sol Sol Metro it's perfect for
you but so egos hey man before the
Oscars I'm working the Oscars not this
weekend but the funks at or Sunday there
you go we got this idea for the pre-show
that airs on Sunday before the Oscars
where you and someone else goes to the
celebrity
lady they call her nurse nurse Jamie
nurse Jamie and she does like all the
Kardashians and yeah I mean you name any
one bunch of dudes she only sees like
these a list clients whatever and so
they think that we think could be fun if
you and Morgan Morgan's the other host
on the show if you two went down there
now Morgan goes there she's a regular
there and so they it would be fine free
cuz obviously you don't fit in the that
mold be fun for you go down and get some
spa treatment like all right I get paid
to do this on you and you like a spa I
mean no I've never really been to one do
you you don't get your nails or toes
done no no I mean I've got my diamond
guide not ingrown toenail I went to a
got a pedicure yeah it was nice I feel
bad for it's something you would like I
like massage it curious yeah yeah
[ __ ] like a like an pedicure on my
feet sometimes my feet are really jacked
up for a movie I had to have my feet and
Nelson I hated it so I go to this nurse
Jamie and we have shoot all this stuff
and she gave me this like it was this
they put caviar on my face like caviar
eggs fish eggs yeah fish roe and then
then take this machine and was like
doing all this crazy [ __ ] yeah face oh
it's electrical thing electrical and
cold yeah ain't cold that [ __ ] works
oh no it worked she literally we did
before and after ha it is not next
Sunday before the Oscars you guys see it
this [ __ ] works my wife's house right
now I was like you know making fun of it
not really making fun to say is this
really gonna work and even off-camera
mascar and it was crazy cuz she goes
your side sleeper
I went how did you know she goes cuz one
side of your face in your body if you've
you're slightly but it's actually bad
for you for your skin for your body ham
that's what I do you should sleep on
your back but she goes cuz one side your
face it so I can always tell when people
come out unless she's breasts you've
been doing for 25 years like she does
house calls to like I mean you name it
the biggest in the world she face
actually yes gets thrown off gets thrown
off
she cuz I'm sure that's how she's like
puffy on one side and he she was all
time she's your face is red yes
sensitive skin so did all the stuff to
my face it really worked it also takes
the red down like it evens it out mm-hmm
works like a [ __ ] it's so funny
to me though it's just you know I'd see
a patreon this is my job right yeah I
love that it was easy too
yeah that's great yeah it's a good time
you're good for it they need a big
masculine presence I can't believe how
much it is though I could not I'm like
who would pay this man how much is it I
mean just a few things I did yesterday
you don't mean thousands and whatnot
cheese yeah what no in the waiting list
is mm-hmm
I can't give him that if I wasn't with
the cheese snow well your face looks
fantastic thank you sir I'm glad you
notice yeah it's wonderful thank you
your your cheekbones are so flush and
thank you those okay you know what I was
up at 5:00 Judy and she opened your face
up a little but she doped my face up
yeah yeah and said in today I woke up at
5:30 a.m. I surprised my son with
balloons you know what you don't do as a
dad in when your kid turns two and when
he's first wake up in the morning you
don't brush into his room with balloons
dressed like an [ __ ] yelling happy
birthday they don't mic now it's not the
good way to kick off his second birthday
yeah kind of ruined the day set the pace
of the day yeah he's at Disneyland with
his mom and grandma now that's good I'm
working and you're working don't do that
to two-year-olds now they're like what
fruits of milk is with the giant in a
balloon excuse me rounds for the rest of
his life Oh God the bad move he's so
goddamn cute he's cute first birthday
chemist it's two years he's two years
old and I'm starting recognize some
stuff you don't know it's his birthday
yeah maybe sing happy birthday to him
what cake get some cookies he's at
Disneyland so he knows like it's cool
but we have a season passivism then I
know so it's like you know he that's
great but do they like it to be my my
son at 3:00 was on a ride that he just
shouldn't have been on it was one of the
things in zum-zum yeah all right Sheila
and Tiger loves it loves it because they
because he loves Lightning McQueen from
cars lived the actual [ __ ] car there
that talked kind of how they do it
Disneyland is nuts man you know I need
to go and a gentleman reached out to me
I forgive I can't find where you damned
me but from Legoland he go to Legoland
but Legoland isn't goddamn near San
Diego my kids simply too far yeah
liked it it's too far as well of course
it's too far of course it's too far
when's the best time to go to Disneyland
where the lines aren't insane Monday
through Thursday okay
so Tuesday Tuesday would be good and
then what you do is you there you go a
little secret for you guys we do kiss
barking the nightmare right suppose you
have a stroller yes you don't just Park
take the shuttle you won't feel like a
peasant on the shuttle right that's
right he pull into the Hotel valet it
that is walk across because I [ __ ]
hate shuttles I won't run a car faster
take a shuttle there's nothing that I
refuse I refuse to do shuttles nothing
ballsy out more everything I stopped I
stopped flying American Airlines at La
cuz sometimes you have to take the
shuttle the worst I won't do it it's the
worst I've missed my flight for that you
know it's the only diva move I've ever
pulled with you know with Showtime go to
New York next weekend I'm traveling a
lot there well you know everything all
good I'm it's not I don't find me
American Airlines because that that hub
in LA when you have to take the shuttle
it's shown without their line no offense
the way it works in LA for you guys they
don't know is the it's American right
American American if your honor
whatever plane you so you gotta go
through TSA regular just get in the
goddamn Airport then you get to American
then you gotta go through a no got away
in an another line to get on the shuttle
to go outside the airport then when you
get there you waiting another line to
get into that weird American Airlines
and then has all the [ __ ] food that's
right I can't stand it and that's the
reason I switched over to Delta
I don't fly American anymore for that
exact race Delta's good JetBlue ones
Austin been on JetBlue I please
outstanding you know vergence old
they're all basically Alaskan air now
that's a bummer did you hear what
happened no the the guy who what's his
name Richard Branson Richard Branson he
sold some of his shares to some guys and
like thanks bro you the odd man out now
I sold it
oh my god the shitty story cuz Branson
said that you can make a fortune or you
can make us a fortune in the airline
business all you have to do is start
with a larger fortune
yeah yeah yeah cuz you'll lose money
yeah it's gonna screw them
dude how about oh I was talking about
this son bring my breakdown I starting
the chin there's just and I got updated
yesterday there's a show you would love
it I know you don't want your ton TV
beat load on Netflix called a last
chance
you and it's basically like stud
top-five recruit Division one athletes
that are at Florida State
Syracuse EU UCLA USC and they're [ __ ]
ups like maybe they failed a drug test
or slapped a girl this one that's that
use a five-star recruit quarterback at
floor state this girl was yelling at him
and he punched her
so can't do that so I remember that was
that a common video yes I remember we're
actually defendant yeah little bit
because we should call them the end yes
come anyway yeah so yeah there's
repercussions for everything I agree
with him some kind of exonerated right
in court kind of so anyways so five-star
recruit is life's kind of [ __ ] up he
gets kicked on floor state so a lot of
these guys go to JUCO cuz they can just
be there for a year or two years then
get picked backed up by a Division one
so they all go to this school and East
Mississippi it's where you go it's the
number one spot there's no where it's
like it's like they like detention they
destroyed teams like 92 zero they like
the one team they're like 75 to zero
what yeah they just destroy so but it's
a new crop of guys every year so there's
this guy long story short cuts on the
big round breakdown but so they have all
these NFL players the coach buddy is
[ __ ] terrible
he's the worst coach I've ever seen the
worst guy at this Tennessee you're not
in Mississippi Mississippi's the worst
[ __ ] game that's him terrible
terrible leader not a good coach anyways
there's a there's a gentleman on there
named Isaiah on season two his name is
Isaiah comes from a broken family foster
he's bounced around foster homes but him
and his brothers stuck together right
his brother went to the same school and
I talked about yesterday you'll enjoy
this chin kind of a sad story so him and
his brother played there stud receiver
him star running back number one JUCO
run back in the nation he's supposed to
go to Auburn Alabama his brothers at
Indiana right now starting receiver they
say he supposed to be the biggest freak
of all time from Indiana no so I talked
about this right yesterday
fans hit me up him and his brother look
it up chin him his brother are in jail
for murder they murdered some teenage
[ __ ] man boy [ __ ] guys oh yeah he was
the nicest guy in the shot man you don't
get [ __ ] any
this ah that's such a bummer and you
talked and you felt so bad for him on
the show what a waste he had a horrible
upbringing it's just him and his
brothers his brother works for the team
his other brothers in Indiana and there
they're always together he has this
girlfriend he's gorgeous and the talk
about starting a family together and she
has a miscarriage so he's going through
a lot during the season he gets hurt and
you suppose so depressing to me dude
and then someone goes dude I saw you
mention you know last last chance you
did you ever hear what happened I say
I'm like no I clicked my [ __ ] this
fake there it was google it man
uh what upshot ever sent me that can't
murder people
hey take my mind off that depression
there's 20 sexy female athletes I just
want to make sure everything's alright
over there see Lindsey Vonn won bronze I
sure did I watched be kind of years old
a little emotional be honest with you
emotional yeah because like she's such a
she's such a she's she wears her heart
on her sleeve man these athletes are all
very good athletes that's all I wanted
to see that they were good athletes um
you know she's she's out on dude America
you know what I know what pisses me off
about the Olympics i watch it are you so
frustrated man especially the Americans
it's like the one thing we've just been
[ __ ] up this one of our worst Winter
Olympics in a long long time a long time
we're killing it in like some of the
snow games like snowboarding and stuff
like that but [ __ ] man yeah it's like
last night watching the girl and she
falls down like dude or the boy who's
supposed to be you know the the Chen
yes Nathan Qin right JD metal or he just
no [ __ ] no Finn no he dropped the ball
son well uh Lindsey Vonn that that whole
course you learn a lot bode miller was
talking about it like how they take the
turns people missing the turns falling
you're going so fast one mistake the ice
gets that the snow gets more icy so a
veteran move is to say let it what they
do the veterans Lindsey Vonn is they go
they go all right they look at the wind
and they then they'll have wind counts
nobody like the winds supposed to pick
up a little bit later go early so they
go I'll take five slop five and they'll
go down and take you know they don't to
be the first one because there might be
a regularity and their coach can tell
him so I'll go down the fifth one and
that's what she did and that
that helped her a lot because the wind
was howling off it works out in the
Olympics it does so you can say were you
gonna go oh yes we have to vaccinate I
love it though why won't hang on you're
ranking so if you're not yeah yeah so so
you forget to go down first to get see
where you place that's right yeah so so
so uh but the wind with the wind kicked
up and so for a huge portion of it bode
miller was like there's nothing to do
about the wind it's gonna hit you now
the woman from Norway for whatever
reason she was not supposed to but she
took a silver she just figured her way
through that wind she just he goes I
don't know what it is she might have her
aerodynamics Keith whatever she did she
did perfect Lindsey Vonn was she was in
second place
yeah bumped down for my girl but she's a
killer like some crazy Lindsey Vonn 33
it's not that old when you think about
it but but your body goes when I heard
her talk when I when they were like can
you believe this woman when the oldest
I'm like 33 and they've all crazy
injuries like downhill skiing really
[ __ ] people up it's like it's a very
scary scary thing what about us and she
I think she had the fastest time on that
mountain during the practice runs um so
when it was time for her to go you know
she's just some oh and by the way
difference between 1st and 4th place in
downhill skiing 6 yeah is that fast how
[ __ ] crazy is that say anything
though but that's realize that's
anything that's sports
I mean [ __ ] so then your suit could make
a difference Lola I mean look at the 40
yard time if this that's the demonstrate
you being a first-round picks a cramp
that's sick millions of dollars that is
you man that's very enough that sports
in general yeah it is baseball so one
second is an eon two seconds is crazy to
say I mean Tuesday's you know you don't
have a just I run a four or four or five
five who like so so I'm not gonna
comment you know I mean drift I got to
run faster if I want to get one on one
foot how about dude we in Tigers how
about my boy Loren Landau he's the head
certain condition coach at the Broncos
now he just got me no [ __ ] Wow I'm
Lauren yes and I worked out with a dude
my buddy Kevin Bay Bay and who took me
through this great workout he has a gym
and
where the [ __ ] was Lauren and he said he
goes he goes we were talking about
different guys and how he doesn't agree
he goes the one do this legit is [ __ ]
because he's been doing his whole life
is Lauren Lando [ __ ] 25 years well he
fixed my back how about that
yeah I mean Lauren's I mean as big as
they get I kept having back issues you
know Lauren Lauren works with Peyton
Manning Tim T I mean okay I mean ya know
everyone knows Lauren it is not world
yeah alright guy there's a reason the
Denver Broncos sign of a hat they don't
really [ __ ] around football players
don't really [ __ ] okay go back that
picture look at oh yeah look at that
that's before Shane Carwin fought Brock
Lesnar and I thought the training
partner Krista shirt Shane's warming up
obviously looks nervous that's [ __ ]
there I just got done from irking some
dude and we jumped in the back there big
boys he looks huge I was a good night
Shane was enormous Trant dude his head
first time I met Brendan that's right
with Shankar's right went to dinner I
couldn't believe you could not get over
Shane well we arm wrestled beat me no
but his hands his hands are so [ __ ]
weird big remember I mean yeah he'll
he'll just pick you up and an average
man he'll pick up and squeeze he doesn't
have to Biagio squeeze you to death
yeah you definitely could how about
least her boeing's in that picture at
least can my show in Denver I should
have guns in the back and we're talking
he's the [ __ ] he's the best he's all ass
he's the best
lassen chassis no no TJ Dillashaw is his
next-door neighbor all right no TJ
wrestled with him every night every
night they wrestle for like an hour and
Lisa is a monster he's a monster
oh my you would never like he doesn't
look like defeated in high school you
eat be rested with Ben Henderson at in
college monster yeah where I forget what
that's what school that some JUCO school
they went to but he was saying his son
also at least least her bones junior you
know he's already wrestling at frijoles
and he's like 12 or something like that
I've known him since he was tiny I
remember when a little Easter Boeing and
Rashad little Rashad were wrestling it
was so cute we wrestle and we'd go
through practice we had done the little
Rashad and little Easter jump out there
moms I mean tiny little dude so now Lisa
he's just stunned obviously because his
dad's when teaching rest since he was in
diapers and he's you know this new stud
and he said Lisa goes yeah
how's he doing zag this llama [ __ ] the
other night tell him to do something he
said shut up dad
at least you know leasers like the top
might be the toughest person I know you
guys go downstairs he's like wait you go
downstairs you want to talk about your
guys stairs he's getting at least say
take sheriff I know you're this badass
do something let's wrestle and least
through this I [ __ ] him up but didn't
hear them just now just [ __ ] out of him
Posey as well oh my god so you have
least least years no one like came in
when I forget her silver before you know
we're fighting goes he gets you into
submission you take your thumb and you
just Ram it right up his ass home like I
was before Nogueira in Brazil like I
feel like that's a bad idea
Brazil bro that's what you do he's just
that guy kind of built like a silverback
like he's kind of built he's got that
short back in the big putt and she's
just emotional guy you do not want to
mess with yeah everyone that picture you
picking on your head at nightmare yeah
nightmare yeah nightmare where in Brazil
could he be whiter yeah he's so wide
he'd be any wider dude I remember we
were in Brazil my my manager likes
McMahon you reelect yeah I thought like
damn day every week long
she died shoutout to Lex we were in
Brazil Lex was feeling all frisky was
like I used to wrestle in high school
and least was like cool man I got done
with my workout this is right before I
was fighting and like me at least before
you tell me I'm defeated
undefeated high school he was a national
champion think wrestler and then head
coach at a University of Northern
Colorado on the page he came out of like
a whole different just a monster but he
grew up wrestling like the him and his
dad was wrestler his dad was a wrestler
so wrestling family so Lex is feeling
froggy my manager Lex you know big guy
marine very big - nice game Lex gets up
and starts John Lee stir and least her
whooped his ass for anyone so bad really
oh my god snapped him down his forehead
hit the ground he pops up he we were
laughing so hard yeah you don't [ __ ]
around
yeah but that whole stories about Lauren
they're one of the good guys man he's
wanted that job forever and what he
thought was so quick he's right in
Denver you were just painting Manning he
works with all the offseason NFL
isn't that a pinnacle first rank coach
yeah yeah and if there's nothing he's
just one of the smartest guys I know man
yeah Lauren lambda well I know I can't
there did when I had my back problem it
was really bad like and I I because I'm
not you know when you have an injury you
tend to think it's gonna be permanent or
something or you can't imagine it
getting better like I just kept [ __ ]
hurting my back he gave me some goddamn
exercises that I do to this way I'm
telling you right now all [ __ ] aside
I got to give my boy Leo flour some
credit to play do you want ball but but
Lauren gave me these exercises I [ __ ]
you don't have problems with my back
anymore my lower back that's crazy I
gotta fix my neck now got a problem that
Lauren dude how about how about Lauren I
remember I I got the call I was so I
worked with Lauren to get ready for the
NFL all I work is going all through
college all for my pro day everything
get to the NFL then I had talked him for
probably five years whilst pursuing MMA
and then I get the call to do with The
Ultimate Fighter I was like I was just
training myself strength condition just
running all the time and when I called
Lauren his best training I've ever had
and he met me for lunch
and I just had this whole pitch she
never worked with any MMA fighters ever
I had this whole pitch I need him he's
like dude I don't know anything about
the sport I'm like I know by I need
someone man we can figure out together
he said come down I'll put some time to
him down sake just show up this time so
he started writing the play and reaching
out to other people I'd send in my
schedule he's just trying to figure out
this monster of a schedule between
boxing jujitsu wrestling so much
exercise just a different animal for him
football you practicing football is easy
basketball is easy hockey's easy so with
mixed martial arts he's trying to figure
out this puzzle piece and we finally
figured it out and ready guys now he's
wound up I mean he had a but he's just
run a book that was a huge seller on
strength condition for mixed martial
arts do you do you know any athletes now
in the UFC that that just wrestle just
do Jiu Jitsu and just do striking no now
you have to lift right you have to do
something to you know it's doing the
whole day it's a whole the student it's
all different
[ __ ] no man it's so much so hard not
you I'm saying if you go I'm saying but
you it's so hard it feels like wrestling
live wrestling jujitsu you're so
depleted to begin with so it's almost
like no way you're professional athlete
yeah when it's your job it's a different
town yeah you get enough rest what's
your job you know I'm saying yeah yeah I
figure out the schedule though you got
to figure the schedule I don't think
anyone has it down pat that I know yet
so it's it's still you know yeah
it's we're still in the experimental
stage it still is some you know some
guys are you know figuring it out and
then you look you guys you're undefeated
and stuff like that but you know cab
EBEs undefeated but he misses a lot of
fights he has injuries and you know mmm
and he's good at he's amazing grappler
but not the best striker so it it's
trying hard to finally put your time and
no one's figured out yet mm-hm you're
gonna get groups of kids who start doing
MMA so they can just focus on them and
May I think and not all the aspect you
yeah
oh no it's weird man it is where sports
going
I always find it fascinating that guys
were that good look like they're doing
such basic stuff like with khabib like
I'm watching him like oh I see what
you're doing you're just taking his legs
away you're wrapping your leg around his
leg in a figure four now he has no table
now he's on the ground and now you're
just gonna you're gonna keep him down
and it looks like he's doing nothing and
you're not getting up no matter what
yeah that's anything right you think I
catch a football he's I you know you
watch triple G throw Jabbok I actually I
took jabs
so even when when I was watching the
first time I remember watching the Iowa
I watched the n-c-double-a Championships
as a wrestler was in high school and I
was like they're not doing it they're
just doing arm drags duck hunters
they're doing simple like single legs
but it's it's timing it's it's like
Spacek [ __ ] but it's off you ever done
high level wrestling that I even now
when I watched the n-c-double-a Sunday
spin it all get stressed when oh my god
the amount of work and the stress and
the cardio shape these guys stresses me
out all my limbic stressing me out man
I'll tell you what [ __ ] ice skating
needs to revamp [ __ ] man because the
music they're coming out to who never
writes that [ __ ] and the whole dancing
sequence that why not come out like some
Bruno Mars and get the crowd yeah one
man
now they're it's they need you know what
they need they need a [ __ ] happy
gilmore in that [ __ ] they need some hot
girls that could blow out ass yeah and
some fat Hooters in the front and she's
just they're about to fall out and
they're Bruno Mars and she spin in yeah
well the coaches are older and they're
from Eastern that's the problem
yeah it's all good if you just got some
Amber Rose do you ever see that one
black ice skater who was the first
person in figure skating to do backflips
like in the Olympics that's crazy oh
yeah bring that up cuz nobody need to
revamp it like I'm listen the music
they're in it's just as slow and I get
it that's the sport but why not mix it
up like that young aging kid man watch
this nobody's ever done it since she was
just she was a killer she was one of the
greats she's American and she was
criticized for this she was criticized
Oh
they were like what she was a killer
what did she get did she get they did
the coaches did not give her that's
what's wrong sport that's like taking
home runs out of base black gray how
dare you mean can you imagine that what
guts and it took such guts for her and
she was kind of shunned for it she was
kind of like hey dude that's awful one
foots earnest have you seen a night on
you yet nope I can't wait tell you what
man that mom Margot Robbie directed and
wrote it she directed and wrote it what
pretty sure each other
she wrote it I don't thinks I think he
looked that up cuz she's as beautiful as
it gets that she's and she's already
that talented so just on a person I was
sitting next to it's a problem oh that's
a problem no it's a problem you don't
think you're the faculty even Steven
Rogers she I think the things she
produced it yeah that's that's worked
into her contract by her buyer agents
which really just means she's part of
the producers yeah yeah I'll tell you
what though this is creatively you gotta
see it because they break the fourth
wall all the time it's amazing man wow
it's so good I saw in the plane come
back yeah it would I was when usually
it's just movies you see you know
generally she's
she's important in in person she's she
better-looking in person yes she
better-looking because that's what you
often find that's we a lot of people
think that when well yeah but with all
the makeup no no let me explain
something to you what God are there was
that she'll bring you to your knees in a
robe with no makeup
oh but also the sheets so goddamn
talented well that's the other problem
that's a pro she's brilliant remark than
most people this is a problem
it's very strange right people that are
that gorgeous then have it all and they
have it all they have it all
they just do she's ridiculous and she's
from the UK she's from London oh she's
Australian oh that damn it be alright
sorry sorry
Australians put out some good actors man
they put out some you Jackson yeah a lot
of really good actors you know if you
tell me wats you know Hugh Jackman oh he
had a comedy actor he did he was the air
God what's that guy's [ __ ] name his
name the man can sing and dance with the
best of them Hugh Jackman or get
Robbie's Margot Robbie yeah see on
disaster as we say in France it's like
if I see like a gt3 or four I go by and
most like oh my buddy so when I see her
I like even a person I was just like
Jesus Christ my buddy my buddy so you
can say what are you gonna say I know my
buddy uh I don't know this is a little
off the topic but speaking of Margot
Robbie and being beautiful you ever have
a friend who you know kind of down on
his money good-looking guy and gets
himself a sugar mama but no I have no
friends okay well um well I was I was uh
this was about fifteen years ago and my
boy was Spanish ponytail handsome
good-looking guys here great guy and he
was having some trouble but a thanks
with money and to wet his beak yep and
work at the dog park and I got my dog
there and he's got his dog there and a
lady he comes up and she's you know
she's what's how can I describe her
she's not been missing any meals and
she's in a muumuu
well she looks like you know she looks
like she looks like oh I'm trying to be
you know I'm not trying to but she looks
like a woman who would be working out on
in a Richard Simmons video like she's
got some you know she's it to work in
progress
she's probably about 40 and things are
looks like [ __ ] Brian get a goddamn
point and as she's talking and I'm like
and she just goes alright baby
I'll see you in a bit and God by his
ponytail you know [ __ ] and goes oh wow
he goes he's doing it guys oh and she
goes oh can't wait for later like it
like no and I go me guess the dog though
real quick the poodle know what kind of
dog did he have no do you at the dog
park he's there with the dog - no she
wasn't she just came over to say hey hey
so they'd been through yeah they had a
little oh he I met up oh so he's I mean
before he dropped by right he's broke
those graham crackers oh oh this was his
this was his sugar mama so I look at him
I go you shouldn't be what's going on
growing this it's you know it's I have
to you know you do what you do and I
know I you know she just takes my [ __ ]
man and she just and I go I go
how's she look naked it's a disaster I
can't you know the disaster so when she
goes to the bathroom I can look you know
if I look I'm finished but I try to you
know go somewhere special I wish you pay
them it's a disaster she was paying his
rent and then his car and they're broke
he's dead broke I don't promise I mean
either I was like no I couldn't do it I
I couldn't get enough it's the problem I
can't that's a visual guy yeah cannot do
it she was a if there's if there's a
weird smell in the room yeah margot
robbie was but making my bed and brian
key and ripped a horrible fart it would
not work I know you mean I'm so
sensitive to that stuff yes well pooh
pooh smells don't go and go with sex my
brain goes comedy my friend goes not
happening comedy doesn't go sex I'm a
comedian I don't want you going he no I
don't want you laughing or making jokes
when I'm about to get down and then and
and a lot of a lot of loose skin and a
lot of like when you're when you're five
the bad numbers on her bad numbers and
again I don't I don't like making fun
anybody for having away problem I really
don't but she was so sloppy like she was
sloppy but she had skin time of the
salon boy she had skin tags on the
bottom of her to color the gram on her
neck she had skin to has around my neck
so she didn't take care of herself she
was kind of one of those people where
she had yes she was uh I'm trying to
think about what is the like you know
when people have those those the things
and she was just like yeah she was of
the moles bad bad numbers and what I
mean by that is I'm talking 5 3 mm 2 2 2
2 2 2 O 5 3 2 your body must being a
tough spot he was in a tough spot
he's right have you ever thought of
doing this Esther no III couldn't I
would just you know I'm a comma dad I'll
bite the very good I'd rather call my
dad I got great daddy
listen me dancin daddy here's the thing
I'm daddy if you don't give any money
instead of a picture I'm gonna have to
go play with this that's right to make
the bills daddy I would rather call my
dad daddy and say daddy it's your son
I need money I'd rather do that and he
would never let me live it down but I
when I was working at La box and when I
was in between football transformed do
with my life I was it that's the one of
the coach at LA boxing and I'd go at
6:00 in the morning
well there's a ton of it's all soccer
moms yeah somewhere hot somewhere not
but the amount of business I got to
freaking come to their house while their
husbands gone or something like that and
I was certain man but then I call that
Ultimate Fighter than that like it was
kind of pointing in that direction but
the ultimate fighters call didn't come I
probably would done something stranger a
little bit of change now did you get was
it because you're you're hungry eyes did
you was it very open could you have had
sex with a lot of those women if you
want every single one every single ask
me again ok let me ask you again now and
think about this don't just I die young
but they don't just jump to Vulcan dojo
cuz they're a lot how many were
where they would be would you say Bob
1550 yeah 15 Mary Mary house Harlan
Highlands Ranch a lot to lose now
careful because I was like why 23 23 see
you're young
yeah I don't women like all their guys
running seven miles a day okay go ahead
a sub five-minute mile gotcha
so let me ask you beyond its hand to
okay now think about don't just go crazy
okay so I think I caught you off guard
yeah you didn't for a second okay of the
15 right how many of them do you think
you could have had sex with every single
one okay how is dad we went that route
every single one is the answer okay
that's the end all the above d-did the
answers DS okay all day but here's
another this is jeopardy it's what is
all of them yeah for 3,000 our guess
here's here's another question and it's
okay how many and you're safe here I'm
just look man out of the trust tree I
was safe with my Adam repo you came out
of the old owl sure it sits on [ __ ] sure
him don't say that I don't I thought how
he perched on a cotton the one who would
do the [ __ ] we have to make that
clear before oh oh oh no it's saying you
can find that I'm saying you're the old
gay our boots on a car my t-shirt Maya
good that's not gonna sell all right
okay
now let me get back except over the 15
and you know every single one I'm sure
yeah
all the above D Alex is the answer how
many did you [ __ ] out of the 15 yeah
well you had to look I just saw you look
up at the ceiling that means you're
searching for a number how many times
that I would I trained him then go to
California Pizza Kitchen after and for
round three okay that's not bad that's
not bad
three it's great well I mean it's a
weird life and it's a weird life oh god
like you 23 even now now I'd say you get
more attention now how about that I was
in justa with this [ __ ] guy and it
was I felt how do I notice it I think
you're off like a [ __ ] spool I think
you're off I don't know won't go there
after this let me buy your lunch you
bought like it was very depressing
I threw have fitted for my Invisalign
after this I sure do know what I'm I
have a small window what time 2:30
come on
Briley for San Diego I'll see what I can
do come on but I felt like a mushroom I
didn't what yeah well who's the mushroom
next to you oh yeah I'm not noticing
them anyway and I don't care no I think
you're awful now I got a little I got a
little insecure because I was like how
am I dressed I feel like no I just had a
black jacket on yeah you looked good
with that pipe get out of here that
honor that obviously sure do you wanna
why
now you're 51 year old gay man I'd sing
crazy never like I would never won keys
what what what yeah gross you're sipping
out of my company has my name on it no
weird bro how dare you throw a party
this weekend and you know damn well I'm
in La Jolla I feel bad about it MJ's in
town - Jason town yeah he's coming town
oh sorry I gonna come to my party no
he's with me and La Jolla that's why
he's in town for God's sakes that really
bums me out why would you so party when
you know worse I wouldn't it but I I do
you know I'm almost a party to love her
I know well it's just gonna be a party
maybe will you set people oh maybe it'll
be my 51st birthday party not what the
[ __ ] I don't know dude I was all over a
lot of people hey Tariq Davey Luke
Rockhold no I got some people - Amanda
scheduled this she starts she said I'm
gonna have people over and I was like oh
okay four and I go well then I'll start
a fight you might be lubbers so I'll
start inviting my peeps because I'm not
gonna just have her papers no that's a
night yeah so I got a have I got I told
you have family guys get when when Peter
given come that's dear she was Peter I
have all my friends over it's a book
night any was so funny I one time when
my wife had the baby was young and she
was in a mommy group with their babies
and I walk in and my wife's there with
her my baby is when this is nine years
ago and the women in there who were all
like they were married they were
thinking about having babies or they
were someone happy they were all tense
it was all like Santa Monica wealthy you
know and I walked in and I was like
hey how you doing oh yeah yeah I'll just
grab the baby and and I was like I'm
talking like this and I'm sick I was
flattening my neck out and I was like
good to meet you guys
all right and I am I would put the baby
goes to sleep real couple scripts here
and I in my mind I was like that guy
that's a sexy dad I had like a [ __ ]
my sleeves were rolled up that's a
second my hair looked good that's Chris
Hemsworth his wife is in there well
forget all that my wife gets in the car
seat hi really you know I don't get
embarrassed she goes I like this Mike be
really waiting for ya yeah and she goes
yes you4re
I go so sexy I go huh and she goes what
was with your low voice anybody you were
kind of like you were making your neck
weird I was so [ __ ] embarrassed
because she was right I was trying to be
sexy failed my acting teacher used to
say don't try to be sexy like somebody
either gather you don't good because
guys guys are vain all guys especially
actors and you see a dude and he'd be in
there and take his shirt off he that's
taking sugar because he was working out
and he'd peel it off slow and Teeter
stop trying to be sexy it's embarrassing
oh my god and that's not what girls like
charmer make her laugh don't peel your
shirt off like it's a cow it's not sexy
is we're like we see the complaints
online of the white walls supposed to
have them painted and the guy who's in
charge of it [ __ ] up they supposed to
be painting on Sunday it's campaigning
this week [ __ ] up let's be on Saturday
so to be paying on Saturday Chin's very
upset about trying they're not killing
we're skin over the weekend so what the
guy did because you know the chins can
wear those people he was my bad messed
up we'll do it next week this dude went
to Ralph's and bodices busted ass M&M
cookies I apologize hey man this makes
it even more [ __ ] blood bread man I
was hungry
remember when we were just soft I heard
a fighter and a kid 3d yeah and what's
his name well I love the Asian guy great
guy oh I know anytime I hear his name
Patera
my brain deletes Nana and I said I need
some I want some hard-boiled eggs I want
some oh my god you gas station no you go
you said he goes what do you guys want
for snacks or lunch and Brian goes on
hard-boiled eggs make sure they're good
they like from Whole Foods and things I
got it man
he goes to a gas station gets brownies
off I don't know a gas station sells
he's got they were made of rubber food
they were discussing a bite I went Brian
he's ready goes you have had a diva
moment they're from Whole Foods I got
lied to Brian know that you lied to me
okay died and I don't know why I was in
a bad mood I'm several times I never
like this and I was staring at him
because I was mad about a lot of stuff
right because things weren't ready and
we weren't prepared I was and I was just
a dick I think I look Jack in the think
in 3d that was so much fun we're at
seven one of the best times ever ever
I'm Ivan thought we should watch him
again man they're so good I hope things
are so funny
so good cannot stop laughing oh we have
to do something like that again yeah man
we would sit down and come up with ideas
it was amazing but remember is really
just you me and Mitch yeah there's a
three-man team basically I'm Fox funded
it but it was all Brian it all fell on
Brian and I had to be honest right and
then Mitch would kind of help out do you
and me would come up with all these key
ideas and I think if we had more help if
we actually were the network who
supported us and like you know we in a
production team I like a legit but not
Fox like there's Bracy the Bad News
Bears we're like Sandlot like it's just
can you hold the camera yeah do a
background no yep
Kenny right no I'll try it it was kind
of that it would always be that way we
were like actors producers directors and
thank God Brian has experience like nope
we can't do this and hope we can't do
that it was you know and when Mitch
Mitch's a veteran you know I mean but it
was it was so much fun we he'd do it
people ask all the time but we've been
offered and off he were like man should
do it we should do it you and I just
need to find time to do it that was it
to be honest like I my Showtime thing
going on now if I stand up gone now II
you have all your stuff the good news
about your show getting green let your
spin off we're just [ __ ] huge that's
all you've ever wanted hopefully it
happens you know that all this happens
it's positive but it's and it's all good
and dandy but snot as fun is
we do find that so I was thinking about
that I was like if if we if you and I
got a team together a real team together
and decided to do a real sketch show it
could be ah dude I think it's good but
before I pitch the show to show time I
met with you named a production company
I met with them and pitched from this
show and every single one they'd
mentioned what's up what about finding
the kid what about you and Bryan doing a
thing and all avoid magic I go we're
ready I mean literally we have a million
ideas right now that would build an
audience a variety sketch show let's
just do it and pull all our friends into
it like Joe Rogan like Chris D'Elia like
will SAS have a board like Rappaport
like like [ __ ] violence yeah
yes collar we have a roster of dude to
guest star on that [ __ ] but you could do
it let you know and like like the Larry
David show it's exaggerations of your
life in these situations with Bryan and
Brendon then you have your friends and
yeah and just make it a little bit over
the top
correct you know [ __ ] that's what I want
to do that's what's fun I know
doing around having fun now what I'm
doing it's just different cuz is it's
it's not fun when you're not with your
friends you know I'm saying do me wrong
I love all you guys I work with it's not
the same now I could do that just the
best one with you and I would get an
interest that yeah especially it was
like because the best would you and I
would come with idea and then when you
see the excuse like oh [ __ ] that was
cool no even stand up I love stand up
you know I love do I land I love stand
up man I love it saved my life and it's
but when we're doing together it's more
in the city now you know when I'm on my
own
when did you [ __ ] when did you say to
yourself I want to be a stand-up comic
you know it was it was terrifying right
because you're like huh to do fine I
always want to do it but then been best
friends with you almost it helped and
hindered me because you're so talented
you but you're such a physical comedian
I was like I can't do that I'm not silly
like that
I'll get daliyah I'm like sure it's
[ __ ] not silly like that and then
when I know I can do this I like to be
honest I always thought I could do it
since I was little and I know it to be
really really honest the one person who
was
you can absolutely do this was Jay since
I was little he said you've always been
holy since I was little a long time in
college Jay brought something up late
but then remember I was training can't
be like you I'm telling you starting to
it stand up but I was making fun of the
guys gonna spar and like dude I'm
telling you start doing stand up like
you're [ __ ] crazy
yeah and I remember we're doing a show a
podcast Rogan Roma's dude just try it
who gives a [ __ ] you're hilarious and
I'm so embarrassed
imma tell if I want to but you're
embarrassed that you're gonna fail it
also you're embarrassed too because
sometimes you've been defined for so
long by so many people around you like
that's a huge thing like sometimes when
you've been one thing to everybody and
you want to make a [ __ ] drastic change
it's a lot of [ __ ] to wade through
because everybody you know it's their
natural thing is to go what what are you
doing but what's crazy and out of anyone
I know this I'll see guys who might not
have any business to a stand and I jog
oh come on man what are you doing I'm
like well I'll check myself like what
the [ __ ] are you to question what
they're doing how dare you huh and
that's me yeah it's true very strange I
don't remember I had training wheels on
because my open mics were at Irvine and
Ontario in front of these sold-out
crowds and you were like you're gonna go
out there by yourself because that's
gonna surprise and remember yeah your
cuz we were riding our first show ever
in Terry oh and I go what do you want to
do he goes buying us oh you're gonna go
up by yourself it wasn't [ __ ] no yours
you can grow up buy a Chevy tells story
that's how we're gonna do that I'm gonna
be late yes I'm gonna be late that was
the bit Bryan cuz he write the we call
mines late for club for the podcast
why wouldn't be late for the live show
so I go out and like act like he's late
ago I'm so sorry guys Bryan oh my god
he's calling me right now I put it on we
do this bit now you're all right I'll
just tell story so that's like your
comfort zone that's like training wheels
for stand-up well people go you've never
done open mikes no I have I have except
for and it was rough in front of 1,200
people in Seattle it's a different
animal it's a different animal then
that's my thing and then Bryan coming it
is crazy that you do that because most
people start with 12 people that they
know and I bring a room they do rooms
and you if you [ __ ] up and you always
[ __ ] up you're [ __ ] up in front of 10
people 20 foot
[ __ ] whatever it is you know and you're
with a bunch of other beginners nah not
that my open mics were those crowds and
then I bombed for sure sometimes come
back and you go I don't think that joke
Sudhir yeah you know it's like that was
my open mic I'm at clouds I told this
story of getting Chipotle with Brian you
know the baton you like it's not there
yet so let's go back and never do that
again and yeah you know well that's
that's that's the I experience it
experience teaches you what's not gonna
work right away I can hear it now okay
it's not gonna work it feels like it is
now you don't know - you're actually in
front of a crowd and trying it out yeah
and I can be my bath their money doing
front of my girl you do for them we all
do that when I would die like we all do
that like what your thing would be like
this I think I'm gonna die I bet you try
joking to be just quiet you go hey guys
this [ __ ] a six yeah but that's
instinct that was good instincts yeah
good filler then you keep moving
something else you see boy he's moving
keep moving keep [ __ ] moving goddamn
yeah I'm fortunate Jay come on the road
with me but it's fun we're good it was
like taran killam never did Santa me and
taran killam is so [ __ ] funny he did
stand-up I was there for his first act
and I think he might talk about this on
the podcast but he did well he did well
but it didn't go as hard as he thought
it was gonna go which I knew and then
that was it he was I was like Taran what
there isn't anyone I live for six years
and he's doing just fine yeah but he
could have done that he was [ __ ]
great day one you know I'll watch a lot
of like I want you to understand up you
know yeah so yeah but you also grabbed a
certain guy through your style right
like you obviously you're Connolly's
different than mine yeah like Bert
Kreischer storyteller Tom Segura Rogen
there's there's different there's
storytellers then there's like guys like
Brian wants to be honest I don't think
what you do there's no class there's no
one can really watch it's either you're
born that way or not it's a very special
type of comedy you know yeah the Jim
Carrey that you you know it's like you
watch that and if you're not that stout
like oh [ __ ] yeah you got everybody's
gotta find their voice that's what it is
it's pretty cool though yeah this next
hour is way less too animated but it's
the best thing I've ever done
Oh February 28th are you gonna be here I
think you know I think you're doing
tonight I don't
rose last night last night you showed
showcase last night Narottam it's next
Wednesday so it's February 28th I think
I'm in New York okay it's gonna be an
hour
it's okay well I mean I thought it was
come come you guys get your tickets
February 24th of D in probably 28th yeah
28th it's gonna be good do I love you
can we shoot that can we fill out - yeah
you are you don't wanna shoot that be no
just for it cuz it's a showcase for your
like behind-the-scenes stuff or actually
shoot it you mean Tim shooter like
you're special
no I mean not just for my my sake and
just to shoot it yeah sure yeah
yeah no no I'm not gonna shoot it is
yeah not this is for the people that are
gonna buy it yeah someone whose goatee
okay so come one come I freaking wish
man I let the Monday I have rehearsal
for my first episode of below the belt
with Showtime Tuesday I shoot the actual
episode Tuesday night I go on a red-eye
to New York the New York to have press
Wednesday Thursday Friday in for
Showtime around the fight Wilders
fighting that weekend and then Friday
night I take the red-eye back to LA for
rehearsal for the Oscars on Saturday at
the Oscars I'm working a lot of work
careful what you wish for kids true it's
good though it's great what about the
shows then if you guys are gone on
Tuesday redeye on Tuesday all right on
Tuesday but Wednesday is the also your
did we figure it out yeah we've never
missed yeah either way there'd be two
fighting the kids yeah make it happen
it's how we roll get some current events
chin do come on Jenny
what do you got you got Jen the first
one is do you guys know what terracotta
soldiers are course no the underground
city I believe right I think Brian's
right they break and become a little
China yeah they all knock over it up
yeah so it's all the thumb no so this is
in Philadelphia these warriors were
donated or actually lent just for a
little while from China they cost this
one in particular cost four point five
million dollars holy [ __ ]
and it was in a museum in Philadelphia
and there was this ugly sweater party
that was like next door to this exhibit
in the museum museum and then one of the
guys just wanted to take a picture with
it snuck in here took a selfie with it
and then broke its thumb and then took
you with him what a [ __ ] so now but hey
but also Chinese don't send these crazy
4.5 million once-in-a-lifetime statues
to Philadelphia let's not do that just
really have to see these in person does
really give a [ __ ] about these facts you
I'm taking the [ __ ] thumb yeah they
know the guy the guys screw they do yeah
I'm sure he posted the picture right we
can't I can't find his picture anywhere
but so these things were over 2,000
years old the dude's name is Michael
rohana
and so China their government the
government is the one that actually runs
this thing so they're asking the u.s. to
like us and I really punish them this is
gonna do no that's a statue stump we
don't give a [ __ ] yeah but also don't
send your stupid statue sometimes you'll
get it he'll get a an issue and we're
gonna fine you might do committee
service mm-hmm Wow worries gonna call
the greatest archeological find the
twins yeah don't send them to Philly or
for that matter anywhere why move them
if you want to see those things like I
don't wanna see [ __ ] King Tut here
you know which they do what you can go
see there's a Porsche exhibit right now
le Museum right let's move on from this
to something creeping or thumb stolen
thumb I mean these dude all of theirs I
got your song all right
so there's a I'm sure your has heard
about this last week a dad that
impregnated his daughter no I haven't
heard I miss that on my colonel right
did you hear about heard about it okay
so the dad impregnated his daughter this
is a crazy story so the dad right now is
out on bond but the girls still in jail
until the judge talks her
so here's the thing 20 years old so
that's the day I had never met before
right so this was that's the girl
restraint hold up hold the [ __ ] phone
these two so they're strange they never
met they got together he impregnate her
they start here's what happened she well
it looks identical to the Napoleon
Dynamite actor oh my god looks I Dan of
water please Peter that's John heater
yeah John John wouldn't swear on camera
cuz he's a Mormon and it kind of hurt
him
John ain't swear on any cameras no one's
really no please look up John I mean he
looks eyes when he's not polling it then
when he looks like him like right there
that's that guy that had sex with his
daughter they have the same nose mouth
and eyes look at that yeah he's a twin I
might be his evil twin Oh John heater's
John's window very mom he's got he's all
grown up right there there is a juicy
movie mister uh I forget what it is
where we he plays with I don't want
drawn blank today is such a great moment
anyways so what happened to this dude
okay so let's look the guy when he was
little when she just had her she was an
infant he couldn't take care of her so
she he gave her for adoption okay so 20
years later she went through social
media to find her dad found him slid in
them diem price linens iums
found him and then they had him her they
had her move into their house so the
wife and the husband her mom they were
together to eat together as a family and
then after a while there was problems
with him and the mother so they were
getting separated and then the daughter
got closer to this to this father sure
they started having sex on believable
that's gotta be very strange creepy [ __ ]
that's two sisters she has two little
sisters too and they're the ones that
found out so that's how I got out
caught them bumping uglies and they have
a dog or they're a baby together now so
it's crazy and now that now is the baby
gonna have I don't know serious issues
right did you get in well quit cuz watch
it so remember the movie who is she
she's my daughter she's my sister she's
my daughter
dude that study basketball that
not--that's study by oh my god I feel
stupid
Gone with the Wind no it's studied by
every film students morals no good one
more come on Bruce all day buy every
filmmaker Bruce Loman it was it was
directed by Roman Polanski who is that
you two had a file platoon no that's
that's all her stuff it was a drag it's
called Chinatown they run away they
heard of the Sheep put-put oh yeah we
did she's my daughter she's my father
Faye Dunaway Chinatown watch this the
same plot and and and who else was in
Chinatown who was amazing yeah call soon
gotcha good job and this is a really
famous scene my sister my daughter right
there watch this this is sick he can't
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on in
your backyard in the pond god jack never
seen such a blonde you're such a bc one
of the greatest of all time didn't they
I don't know yes for flat surface
positively who is she
and don't give me that crap about your
sister because you don't have a sister
seven did you could hit a girl in acid
she's my daughter I said I want the
truth so you could do that bad watch
this hashtag me too this is the
seventies you beat the [ __ ] out of them
can't make it feel like the finality in
other words you find out here
her father her father tell ya see the
whole mood he give a [ __ ] about ya it's
one of the greatest movies of all time
trying to tell us you have to get under
your belt
I will it's it's what a great news about
the incident anyway it was shocking when
this came out like we everybody's like
oh my god right dude she's gonna want
fade unawares a beast
I would love a fair I would love to open
hands slap you like that would you
I'm sorry I'm not sorry I'm sorry I'm EJ
I'm not sorry let me pay I'm your daddy
I'm your daddy I'm your son I'm your
daddy I'm your [ __ ] every day are you
rich so do they arrest that dude for
impregnating his daughter how's that
work it's incest you can't do that right
so legal it depends it what in texas or
Florida you're good aren't you the
certain stage wishy-washy I don't think
you do a lot of time in jail but it's
parts of West Virginia where that's
celebrated anything that was made
illegal namely because one it's weird
but also it's not good big create I can
create Downton right yes yeah that I
know he creates some birth defect
that's so creepy too it's weird
that's her as a baby yeah almost makes
feel sick so sick oh here's another
thing that's sick well what do you think
will you see this shape do you mean hot
no I don't know I
nobody not what I think's happened here
yeah I think that old crazy bad on the
rights gonna push the old young girl on
the left
Jesus railing you do well I thought
we're talking about dark times I'm gonna
say that's father-daughter right there
and I'm gonna say they're the same no
they're on a hiking trip and I'm gonna
say that's right before she swallowed
his no no we're not in trying to help
slowly in Chinatown Gatorade his last
Gatorade ashwaldt its last Garrard this
is right before he opened up that that
day CH that he had in his bag okay but
is right before a bear was right before
she had placed it on no neck his neck
beef jerky roll yeah we have to get him
out of Chinatown Oh
so this guy thought he was you're right
he's his father this girl he was accused
of being a pedophile because he checked
into a hotel or a motel with his
daughter so the people out front thought
he looked creepy yeah and it was weird
that he was with her in the same motel
room that's fair so they called the
police and then he had to go through an
investigation that's a bummer
the girl was crying the little daughter
was crying as is gone going on was it
true no oh thank god yeah that's weird
god no no no no good but also a dad but
I agree good for that you want to be
better safe than sorry and this is at a
Travel Lodge in England it's the second
time it happened to your Lodge I assume
there owns a pedophile I assume I'm
gonna be killed slaughter gonna travel I
assumed so one's gonna rape me that's
right I assume it's it's a torture den
and I'm gonna get there and my doors
locked what the [ __ ]
these windows are really black mask man
comes out gasps gasps huh chapped lips
Wessel woke up and now I'm [ __ ] that's
your Travel Lodge experience they have
like two stars around the world
everything that's a bad situation ever
stay which I imagine England would be
better though this episode is brought to
you by travelpod member mande mur oh
I'll take it there's only two of them
right yeah I got donated to like a like
a movie Museum or something and this one
got went to one of the workers on on set
and he sold it for $50,000 ice Bay Bay
[ __ ] I would have bought that thing yeah
you really think I don't Harry Harry
I'm cells their van and they're out
there they hate each other and he comes
back like hours later he sells his van
he pulls up he's on the scooter he goes
hey Harry done goes just when I don't
think you get any stupider you go and
flora deem yourself I'm gonna get off
thing I take that to Denver it's
hilarious really they trade that in
front they have abandoned this dope ass
van that's a shag carpet dog looked van
yeah baby used to wash his dogs out of
figure I sold that for that it's a great
movie oh man it's one of the best movies
of all time yeah still holds up - yeah I
watch it all the time
oh my god yes 50 grand though 50k but is
that the one they actually wrote on so
there's only two but yeah it is one of
them watch MTV that that show with
babies moms oh gee mom teen mom yes so
do you know this guy yeah hell yeah I
know that guy so he's married remember I
work for ISA of course that ownership
he's married to Jenelle Jenelle is she
has three different baby daddies she's a
nightmare her mom's an amateur former
drug addict so now she's with this dude
what's going on this year's got three
children from different three different
nightmare whole nightmare nightmare her
mom is the most of Judah now [ __ ]
worse and she's she's dating guy with
his hair like that uh she's married to
him okay good hair well that's what he
looks like I hear it was like he started
uh he went on a I guess a hater on
Twitter said something to him and he
responded back in a really bad way
towards C so there's some of the posts
he wrote so oh but what the guys say
this is the guy replying so but what did
the guy say where he lashed out of them
how would you how would you have your
kids treat transgender or gay people and
he goes no no I can teach them not to
associate with them or be that way if
you lay down with dogs you get up with
fleas and just what makes you think you
have the right to tell me how to be a
parent because you think you know me
lmao why don't you go tell the homo
change ends or parents to start teaching
their kids better morals or I forgot
that supposed to be normal
MTV there's a black Janice blac chyna
sex tape and there is it's her giving a
[ __ ] to some guy where I don't I
don't want to do that you sound like you
really want well but what else you know
so there's a girl 16 and pregnant
oh gee C's in OG named Farah she's uh
she did porn yeah her a million dollars
she had porn and on this season they
find out that she's continued to porn
they fire her - oh she's a nightmare by
the way nightmare falls me on Twitter
whatever slim idea nightmare
what else you got Jenny I've tried a sex
tape though huh yeah if I would watch
them it's all rubber what'd you say it's
from a wrapper I don't know she she has
to sign that all over so so did it's not
in a mistake that it's it's not a
mistake and it means I'll text J right
now and he will have it in my phone it's
not a mistake that it's you know who met
she is I don't okay does he have a fat
dick
I don't know hopefully text J right now
assuming that sex tape son oh yeah oh
yeah director that surprised the full
bomb makers aide fired after falsely
claiming apartment students crisis are
actors owned so you know those
especially there's two kids that are on
a lot of new stories a lot of new shows
they're in front of the mic all the time
it really well spoken they're talking
about the the Florida shootings they
were there there's a conspiracy now
going on that those kids are yeah Alex
Jones and all that the same guy who said
that the stonee what's the with those
little kindergarteners were Matt
massacred oh yeah that was that was all
actors and a lie and that's why the
parents are still getting harassed by
[ __ ] and that's how Sean's so and
that's his group it takes J hey you guys
that sex tape jegos you want just the
highlights or the whole thing okay so I
kinda got paid for that sex tape if it's
out there maybe or horde humbly leaked
it you know I talked to everybody at
Tim's no no this isn't a vivid this is a
self only a you now even that no I just
remarried not this not this day and age
so but yet remember it's not new porn
it's not not this from a gentleman's
personal account so he might get sued
and [ __ ] I know he's screwed right he's
some rappers you she was like oh let me
film me sucking his dick now she's known
to be promiscuous I paid stripper but
the thing is what she does is frowned
upon
she just coughed it no all right I just
heard I said something she had sex with
Rob Kardashian when he's 300 pounds he's
in shape now I never kid together name
dream dream sit on that first day
God and we're back what else you know
what here's the shape now he's getting
in shape he's doing some weight you got
really really big yeah huge he's getting
better as a sock line he's trying
figures trying to find his niche with
all sisters you know yeah nightmare yeah
night don't want to be that guy mm-hmm
all the money in the world don't be like
that um I wish you know on this school
shooting um uh as a gun owner and like
when all you had said is all you said
one time was can we admit we have a gun
problem and you got 1 million like
emails walking you don't know you're
talking about time again we admit though
that there is that this is not
acceptable
I know can we admit at least that that
you want to call it amounts a health
problem you want to call whatever you
want to call it I don't care but um
there's gotta be something we can do and
I don't know what the answer is I know I
know you can use a van to kill people I
know you can use a knife to kill people
I know you can use lost but there's
clearly a gun issue with the school
shootings you know you know you know
this is a bummer I read this today
bulletproof backpacks have got all six
of a percent in sales yeah I mean that's
that makes sense
I'm worried a much of a bummer is I'm
worried about my might my elementary
school-aged children getting shot up
because of some nut you know I there's
so many things to worry about so do we
have just do we have more security with
God's the things we do you ever feel
like it's too late to do anything like
we can't go get banned guns that's gonna
help the next generations down the road
in like 60 80 years but right now in
this current state we're in the culture
in there's so many guns circular out
there on the black markets too easy to
get the regulations yeah so what do you
do so I was in Arizona and and two guys
two guys well CB Dollaway came to my
show great guy great guy he carries a
gun you know he's in a lawsuit DFC I
didn't know he was getting off the
elevator got hurt and can't work right
now for a minute no he's he's in Seabees
in the training camp right now he's
gotta fight permanent irreversible
damage to his back well you screwed
though cuz the the courts can go weak
but you fought after that
yeah just gonna help ya butter beezly's
and he carries gun you can carry a gun
on on the outside of your body in
Phoenix like the wild where hundreds of
loonies my my [ __ ] MC goes he goes
she pulls out a Glock he's on stage I go
you have a gun yeah she's like well
carry-ons everybody in Arizona carries
gun so that my my feeling is what do we
do do you want to go do we do everybody
just should everybody just have a
[ __ ] gun so that when somebody opens
up you can shoot him back no no one has
good enough shots we talked about yeah
so then what I can't like how do we stop
it I would like school Yvonne must
attack this sounds like people waste
smart and me attack this issue it feels
like the people who are smart could
actually make it different aren't
attacking this issue we all want us to
the government all the red tape we all
go let's all agree no one wants the
Oscars done gun owners gun not though
everybody wants to stop spree shooting
right there we all want to stop the
tragedies and obviously when a guy has
make a 47 eighties opening up with all
that noise there's only one thing that's
gonna stop him in that moment right
that's a ball another bullet that's just
how I got to be honest I've always been
you know this so anti-gun so and then I
had a issue with my home you know we had
a scare now I have two shotguns and guns
around the house and alarms and got that
guards dog I get this guard I tell you
what now that's the real a better [ __ ]
yeah now do I have any legit training
I've been to the range I fired that shot
gonna find my gun I have I the training
I have is hallo ina first gun as you can
I don't have a play bots Xbox
Playstation me every gun owner will tell
you play in the NRA
they'll tell you the first thing to do
education like I go there buy a gun and
they go you can use you can you can use
a safety best thing with your children
educate the [ __ ] out of them about a gun
teach them about supers in making not
such a mystery and I have this great
safe so that you off see my child can't
get do it stuff like that but tell you
what someone breaks in now we have a
plan I have a shotgun come on in you're
not worth oh and but yeah I get by the
Malinois let me know how that goes for
you and then there's an alarm the cops
with the street you know yeah a lot of
lines of defense you need a lot of lines
of defense and then if all breaks down
all the weapons and get through the dog
and the alarm and my shotgun you know a
little smile we're go hand
a little something you know a couple
things
as long as Cain Velasquez or Travis
Browne don't break in I'm good but if
it's regular now if Travis brown breaks
in as a mask I'm like yep
then again you're protecting your family
so he better pack a lunch yeah but still
a beets ugh that's my hands full he's
lost bunch of fights now but still have
your hands full
uh yeah no no I I don't know man I don't
know what to do I just don't want this
anymore yeah I hope someone weighs
smarter than both of us figures it the
[ __ ] out both sides I said wait smarming
pro-gun anti-gun government people are
actually can make a difference figure it
out cuz this talking about it doesn't do
any well what's crazy is that you you
you can do all the background checks and
everything else but then you get people
have no nope mental history they have no
random three random they just taste like
in Vegas a 64 year old man what with no
no even his brother was like but put the
accent both his family there's family
super dark and that comes out he's
actually really [ __ ] up but yeah the
thing is the access he has to those
automatic weapons is the issue but even
if even if right now America were to go
out we're banning all automatic weapons
there's none that there's so many circle
around yeah and by the time they ban it
those crazies go I'd stock up on Mac
weapons then the dark web I can get
anything out that's true that's true
that's not that's not laws not more laws
they're already ton of laws I know
and the answer is not I don't know
you're not gonna you're not gonna
legislate your way out of this problem
no what did you see him in Whittier
which isn't far from here
some kid they found out through various
sources was planning to do a school
shooting up they went to his house and
found all sorts automatic weapons and
Arsenal's and stop and before it
happened that's the answer
figuring out a way but why these kids do
it a lot of my bully to the the weird
can the class stuff like that yeah so I
don't know kids also don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if your bully don't their answer
isn't to shoot people for god sakes but
then it's mental health where do you
start their their kids are not showing
signs I don't know man it's such a
problem to tackle and it's such a
[ __ ] from tackle because you'd start
at the random no
you can't really stop they've always
said yeah it's not bullying either
you also can't stop somebody who's
willing to take their own life when they
want to take a bunch of other life right
that's a suicide mission most of the
time yep they're so how do you how do
you fight an enemy like that well I wish
I did I really do I just I would like to
have a gun to shoot back I know that's
Tim Kennedy's guys a lot of those guys
who are trained like I'm never anywhere
without a gun
you know and because it would be nice as
soon as opens a hole I'm beat so when
you say you want a gun remember this is
student shooting other students you want
every student on that campus with now in
high school now remember you in high
school god I had a slingshot and I've
like huge oh yeah I leave my friend you
when you're young and your cerebral
cortex isn't isn't only through your
life's over to death inside [ __ ] you
know of course so you want them all to
have done now you want to teach or don't
you know I'm saying do you know that
what was it the lot of societies and
ancient sighs would basically take all
the boys from 14 to 20 and put them
essentially in the military and you're
dangerous sweet and there was no crime
because that's who really does the bulk
of it and so now they're learning how to
be warriors but they're learning
discipline there are they're part of a
community when you're doing that here
we're way past that I don't we were show
past fixing this it's so scary man what
else you got you real quick with the
bully thing though so I think just my
personal opinion I think it's just the
kids with mental problems that get
bullied that do that I think people
regular kids they get bullied they take
it out on themselves or they yeah
exclude themselves they kill themselves
yeah you're right man sir and a lot of
times I'm with people who are on the
spectrum like they have as burgers and
stuff they don't know how to make social
connections and they get really lonely
and depressed and then they they you
know they can't make friends they don't
know why yeah that part of the brain
isn't very they don't know how to read
social cues and stuff it's so [ __ ]
heartbreaking and then they're alone
then they get despair and all that stuff
I don't know so no story be nice Jose
that's what you raise your kid that
we're all the same you know I'm saying
you don't want your kid being Louie
include include the maybe include the
weird kid that kid is out and try to you
know at least try to cause that weird
kid wouldn't know
not only psychos and kill people a lot
of times that we're kids the creative
Kanye and he's also that he's that kid
as you can create great things he might
be the likes to drop us out Bryan Callen
you might be the breakouts who turn into
[ __ ] moon don't be mean to him cuz
you might want be honest I don't like
the with your mouth don't drag that I
was very popular yes sure Brian Brian
was the small guy one to wrestle had the
rich gun you're hanging up for snacks at
its class loser Atticus [ __ ] yeah I was
wrestling cute to scale [ __ ] Jim happier
one bulletproof backpack that's what
we're [ __ ] coming to I would actually
buy my kid a bulletproof backpack I
would just send a private school [ __ ]
doesn't have a private schools by the
way I want to see this fight I want so
yeah UFC actually tweeted out this is do
you guys want to see this fight where'd
they get that idea
wait a minute so it's a it's fascinating
about the first professor Gauna versus
Derek Lewis
that's an intriguing fight I know I'm
done to my head got in your head I know
what you're gonna say
I'll take Francis oh um cuz he just he's
got more speed hits so hard you know
what I I
I don't know if you had to get in my
head I'm gonna need some time
don't shoot me right away I'm gonna need
some time to debate it because neither
one's gonna win any race as far as
cardio no one's
jump in the Boston Marathon both have
insane power I'll tell you what Derek
loose might have more power than Francis
he's not as explosive but he touched you
you're going to night-night
Derrick Lewis both awful wrestling both
awful jujitsu that's a great fight hold
on that's a great fight if that thing
gets out of the first round a terrible
fight yeah make it show that's right
you're right if it gets out of the first
round in two [ __ ] [ __ ] now if they
fought every Saturday I would watch it I
will say that every Saturday if they
charged me 39.99
I would buy that every single Saturday
yeah because that things like get out
the first round
it's amazing fake strong man now whoever
lose that fight probably under the road
yeah kind of Ghana is just a [ __ ]
warrior the lord have mercy I don't know
I don't know man who does any want you
for a takedown no no I think they just
slug it out what does Derrick Lewis his
background what a what a record he's
already amassed I mean just that power
his resume is more impressive than uh
yeah his uh his resumes Mort he means
beat in the UFC is way means if then fro
yeah oh yeah cuz Francis has actually
had perfect matchups
right besides Curtis blades we did did
beat so I can't knock him on that
Derrick Lewis remember he beat Roy
Nelson burner raised to one of seven
siblings oh he's also a great guy
oh and guess what else he's good at
social media he's a monster he's
hilarious
yeah trained boxing go down to his
record that's so impressive look for it
so first of all he beat Travis Browne
which Travis Browne verse Francis is
actually the tough fight for for Francis
he beat Roy Nelson meet Gabriel Gonzaga
now when I look at that right now Singh
black belt Gabriel Gonzaga black belt
all those guys can grapple can't get him
down Marcin tabara
you know he's that you took him down did
some work now he did get knocked up by
Jack may yeah he did get knocked out by
Mitrione skip that was back in the day
that's problem knocked him out Oh
remember he also knocked out Gio
Rochelle now Jared and that's how black
bees got to UFC fight Jared Rochelle was
Oklahoma State national champion
three-time all-american really yes you
know what take your black [ __ ] dude
he's hit 30 fights or something I didn't
Sturman number five every in the world
sucked yeah no black bees he I he just
didn't seem like you wanted to be there
the other night but outside that he's a
[ __ ] nightmare nightmare any in
there's no quitting that kid to that
trust
fight using some tough positions
nighttime quit man
I thought he killed Travis when they
should not let him get that at your shot
in I thought he killed him I get dare
close in that fight yeah
who are you gonna say before I suede
this Derrick Lewis yeah yeah they're
close one percent 100 percent Derrick
Lewis
I don't know if they do that nice and
yeah but I don't feel like do you see
social media team doesn't talk to the
match I'll tell you something else about
Derrick Lewis when you watch this last
fight he had with marcin - Booya
whatever his name is he that guy was on
his back riding them I mean and he
sloppy
yep and Austin and he still got up and
knocked him out that's what's scary
about his power yeah still did it
how many retweets to them eleven
thousand thousand all right eleven
thousand likes
3563 what if they do it if they do it I
better be in July cuz Francis can't say
no I still want to work to my wrestling
now son [ __ ] that noise and that's what
he's doing right now
Francis is easy shooting doubles and
singles right now and sprawling I don't
think so you better be yeah I don't know
that's great though great fight
hopefully it happens what else yet did
we talk about Fergie's responds to all
the hate yeah you did
I think no we talked about how bad it
was they came out after that she just
basically said that yeah I felt bad -
after meeting it's where I make fun of
people on Twitter I'm ashamed of myself
pointing it out it was just so bad I had
to yeah I'm a risk taker artistic lady
yeah that's why I said but clearly this
rendition didn't suck the antenna one I
love this country and honestly didn't
might try my best that's all I said we
owned it she overstepped she tried
something it didn't work out that that
happens if she's successful as she's a
risk-taker issue well she recognized she
didn't didn't connect my bat it's also
the all-star games who gives a [ __ ] yeah
how about that
hitter best it's funny it's one for the
ages it's like yeah well it's not like
she's mean known for them we all we all
try to create some great tracks yeah oh
yeah Fergalicious they did part of what
makes her successful is that she's old
she doesn't settle for a status quo what
else you got Jen that was
it's those were good thanks those were
good
do we have can I get some color on
what's next in the Olympics I need to
watch some [ __ ] tonight
same [ __ ] bro Alpine Skiing I think
you're skating does Lindsey Vonn have
one more run
it's me tough to find out what's left
I'm excited I don't give a [ __ ] about Oh
while we're talking I don't give them
[ __ ] about toboggan I don't give a [ __ ]
about bobsled and I don't give a [ __ ]
about curling I don't think that much
about any of it women's ice hockey yeah
well you're skating B were you gonna be
brother let's wrap this job come see me
in Huntsville Alabama first of all
February 28th get your tickets Melrose
improv in Los Angeles I'm doing an hour
February 20th starting at 8:00 p.m. then
you come see me in Huntsville Alabama
stand-up live Greenbow Alabama March 8 9
10 I'm there and I can't wait
this weekend Friday Saturday I'm in La
Jolla San Diego Comedy Store two shows
each night two shows on Friday two shows
on Saturday you tickets now at effect K
calm and then these dates just hit I'm
at levity live March 16th through the
17th oh where where where levity live in
Oxnard California Oxnard levity live
right Club and then Florida is Tampa
sold out west palm is almost filled as
well I get one show on Friday one show
on Saturday West Palm Beach improv
Orlando Sunday show I think is sold out
the check and then this one just
announced I'm in San Jose San Jose
improv March 29th through the 31st San
Jose improv I want to come feature for
you one night in Oxnard let's do it
brother I mean now Bryan Callen will be
there so March 29th through 31st San
Jose and then April I'm in Bakersfield
Bakersfield California to get Steve act
gay for all those but this weekend La
Jolla and then after that is Oxnard
March 16th food
17th get your takes now San Jose
you're up as well t5k calm for Brian and
myself love you guys thanks for
listening this is a farm kid we're out